[Music]
drunk
adamandeve.com you know what we're very
sex positive here on this show uh
lifeline a lot of people call up with
some advice and sometimes uh we give it
to him and if it's sex advice we're sex
positive and i got something for you
look there's a lot of bad news out there
about prices these days you know and
it's nice to know that adam and eve is
still offering the best deal at
adamandeve.com get 50 off plus free
shipping that's 50 off that's a lot
that's half that is off of an
adventurous new toy slippery lube or
almost anything else
you desire that's for our podcast
listeners we'll get 50 off not everybody
just our
listeners right what are they 50 off
almost any item just use the code
lifeline at checkout and voila you get
50 off and
free shipping free shipping so that's a
lot that's even more than half really if
you do the math correct doesn't matter
what you choose it'll all be packaged
and sent discreetly for free it'll show
up at your door people won't know you're
getting what you're getting if you feel
any type of way about that but we don't
because we're sex positive so go to
adamandeve.com select any one item use
code lifeline
n l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e this is an exclusive
offer specific to this podcast
so if you support the show be sure to uh
go and support our show and use the code
lifeline to get you not just the 50 off
but also the 100 free shipping code
lifeline go to adamandeve.com
right
now
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]
all right well i'm chilling chilling are
you chilling chilling yeah i did a show
last night at the hollywood improv and
it was really fun i was doing um
i was doing a show for uh
the i was like because i'm going to
dallas next week or this week i guess
when this comes out and wichita and um
to do shows and i was running my set
because it's been a little bit since
i've done like a a full like i guess i
did 50 minutes but um yeah it's been a
little bit since i've done that so now
i'm coming and i'll be there so go to
chrisleya.com for dallas wichita atlanta
and washington dc and savannah those are
the first dallas is first yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
grandstand prairie uh um
[Music]
it's friday yeah and then wichita
saturday night nice nice nice nice nice
so i asked you if you're chillin chillin
are you pimpin pimpin too uh
you asked me if i was chillin chillin
right when we started at the beginning i
said are you chillin chill and then you
kind of veered it into this other thing
but you interrupted my line of inquiry
next time you just wanted me to say yes
or no
you can answer however you want this is
an open forum you said yes you said yeah
are you chillin chillin now my question
is are you pimpin pimpin yes okay great
i mean [ __ ] magic don juan doing an
interview podcast
yeah okay all right let's go to let's go
to [ __ ] romeo for weather he's on the
street corner hey what's up man it's
raining hoes yeah and we're back um yeah
i'm thinking about getting a news
station going so oh that's really
practicing my interviews has anyone ever
said that sentence before in the world
what i'm thinking of getting a news
station going i honestly like i like to
think that everything has
ever been said right because there's
just too many people and time has been
too long but i would say
one of the top things that has never
been said truly is i'm thinking of
getting a radio station a news station a
news station going i'm thinking of
getting a news station going thinking
about building someone's probably said
radio station radio station but not news
station going thinking about getting a
news station going from the ground up
yeah going to cover the news the world
events you know what i take that back
you know why crazy people yeah yeah uh
gnn remember that guy oh my gosh yeah
dude can we talk about that guy is that
allowed yeah but what was the [ __ ] i
used to know a guy in a coffee shop i've
talked about this on congratulations
okay by the way like and subscribe the
video we're trying
we're not at six hundred thousand
[ __ ] subscribers yet which is let me
just say this
oh [ __ ] yeah that's not good um but yeah
subscribe to super call studios so i
used to go to uh this coffee shop you
know i used to run the block right over
on coldwater and ventura i hated going
there dude so much you're different than
me it was the only place you would ever
go so to hang out with you i had to go
there did you hate it because i ran it
no i hate it because it's like
it was in like a shitty little valley
plaza with like a baja fresh [ __ ]
and like a shitty bagel place you know
love it western bagels don't [ __ ] and
i was there was not a baja fresh until
later on okay it was excuse me okay
uh and now it's a five guys so uh and i
don't go there anymore because there's
no coffee bean they shut it down dude it
used to be a gas station it was nice and
now there's a wells fargo it's all
hoity-toity but whatever you know
um but this was at the start oh no i
guess it
and
so i would go there and i would i would
write it was just back when i would like
write screenplays and [ __ ] forever ago
yeah and um
and uh
this guy was there and you know you meet
all these people i mean there was an old
guy who would always call the mayor with
problems in the [ __ ] city you know
he'd accuse no this is a different guy
this is not that guy the guy with the
briefcase
oh you know that guy yeah yeah oh
there's a different guy you could always
call the mayor
talk about how they were mexican
nationalists taking over yeah right you
remember that yeah yeah you know that
too oh hell yeah okay yeah
that's where the people always fart like
a [ __ ] right oh that's right
that guy would fart like a [ __ ]
the guy who kind of farts where you
don't say [ __ ] because you're like oh i
mean he's dead by now you know what i
mean like oh his farts made it's [ __ ]
smelling like a dead place dude but he
would ha you know what he had in that
briefcase do you remember oh no i don't
remember no
nestle quick
only he would bring nestle quick get the
whatever you would get god pour it in
the thing and then stir it and then put
the nestle quick in his briefcase dude
what a disgusting and then he would just
fart like a [ __ ] because you
know the mayor talk about mexican
nationalists you know nothing makes the
worst guy when's this time you drink
chocolate milk oh i don't know it's toot
city dude well it's toot city i believe
that it's toot city but regular milk is
fine
chocolate milk
honestly toot city how do you know
though when's the last time you did it
all right yeah high school dude and i
would eat it all the time eat it you
know and i would and i would and i would
[ __ ] toot
so much
and it was unbelievable and i stopped
doing it and whenever i i did the you
know the
i stopped doing it wouldn't to it then
drank it with two fifth period two it
all up and uh you know so you figured it
out took it all up and called the mayor
and so um
what if you realized it was the nesquik
that was my oh my god yeah yeah yeah it
not only doesn't make you too it makes
you call the mayor so what about mexican
nationalists so um
so andy where are you going to talk
about gnn i know there was another guy
who was a stunt guy that would always
try to get me into the into buddhism and
then there was another dude that um
[Music]
oh that was the thing where the guy came
in was like oh we got to hang out
sometime and he he had and he said
strictly hetero and kick the door
remember that guy no no no no no dude he
was so crazy you don't know that no i've
told this like it's such a popular thing
to do it's called strictly hetero but he
dude he
he was like oh dude i love your stuff
man he's like we gotta hang out sometime
and bye brother you know me i ended up
hanging out with him of course i love it
dude love crazy people you've always
been like that i know weird [ __ ] so um
so he was like we gotta hang and he was
walking out with four drinks
with four coffee drinks okay and they
were frilly ones who was even they're
all for him probably yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude and he had shorts on and he goes
you know well we got to hang out
sometime he we gotta hang out like yeah
[ __ ] i'm down dude and he goes like
they're strictly hetero and kicked it
with one he kicked it with one foot open
the door and walked out with the tray
dude i will never forget that and i go
oh dude that's pretty i mean speaking of
pimping pimping that's at the top of
that [ __ ] yeah yeah and then that
[ __ ] and i remember the guy with the
briefcase tooted after that so um
yeah so there was another guy who was we
are prelude for getting into yeah
because i want to color the [ __ ]
story about how amazing the coffee bean
is this place was wall-to-wall crazy
[ __ ] it was real honestly coffee
shops are like that though especially at
2 p.m though like when like
no jobs yeah
so um
you know who also used to go there all
the time the comedian chris spencer i
would hang out with him all the time you
know him yeah i do know chris he's a
great guy and a great community uh eddie
murphy was also yeah he would go there
and he'd be like and and he always had
the greatest car and the [ __ ] hottest
hottest chick yeah i know
yeah and and and he would like do that
to me and i would feel so good
yeah he did it to me too so you're not
no no no but he knew me from comedy so
um
so anyway this guy
gregory i don't know
his last name knows
gregory james oh that was god yeah
right no i think that's how he went like
a stage name so and it was gnn he would
go by gnn and he was starting a news
network he see he's the one who said i
know he definitely said i'm thinking
about starting a new study i know yeah
um and there's videos out there i follow
him on youtube uh and he's he's in
florida now do you know this yeah oh
yeah i showed you because i i i gotta
keep up with him he's in florida now and
he's very old and he's in and out of the
hospital and poor guy
yeah um he had like a heart maybe heart
surgery or something he had probably had
covet it was bad um and i just hope he's
doing okay you know he he was he was
always very you know i i have a feeling
he was probably not
mentally sound but uh well he definitely
wasn't right right right i mean i'm no
doctor but yeah he was not mentally
sound and uh but i hope he but he was he
was we would we would hang out you know
and yeah he would he would chill i mean
he's got to be what
60 you know he's got to be old yeah um
and he would just uh you know he would
say
like he had that song remember that song
there's that song on that's what i was
going to bring out go go go obama yeah
go go go obama and now he's a [ __ ]
huge trumper you know the the the thing
about that song the genesis
the behind the scenes of that song if
you will was
he was a big republican and wanted
mccain to win
and he made that song as like a as like
a bridge like an olive branch to to
obama being like okay well you won fair
and square now i'm going to put my
support behind you oh how do you know
did you you you know the gnn [ __ ]
biography you have yeah i have the
behind the story the behind the scenes
dude and so um
is that gonna work yeah go go obama i
mean he's not gonna gregory news network
gnn add gnn
it's definitely there dude
nah i didn't take it down bro
i mean maybe maybe he did because it was
kind of pro obama he doesn't want his
trump oh yeah yeah dude you know
go go go obama
i mean
i mean well the first thing there we go
first thing that came up was janet there
it is wow he's got so many videos that
oh look he looks crazy until yeah and
he'll be like coming to you live from
the fort lauderdale uh starbucks yeah
the you know all right yeah he's in it
so he does the news and just talks about
things that he's read and then uploads
it to youtube
james william gregory james william
gregory william that's right he would
say william like
oh wait wait go to hold on you guys i
mean three first one three first names
james williams he is all trumped out now
yeah now yeah [ __ ] just click on one
james gregory jr
hello ladies and gentlemen it's me once
again
i'm wearing a hat i've worn many times
on my youtube broadcast broadcast anyone
who goes against children or has
has an abortion to kill to murder a
child
who does that for yourself you're going
to heaven
are you scrubbing it or is it cut like
that no it's so whoa
this isn't him though this is uh [ __ ]
anyway dude that is him no no no no no
this is him but this is not his channel
somebody did that oh
anyway dude uh i hope he's doing okay
and he uh but yeah if okay is how he was
it seems like he's doing okay now yeah
up to the same old [ __ ] you know that
makes so much sense earthquakes okay go
back go back one go backwards hello
ladies and gentlemen
earthquake song go to the earthquake
song oh there's another song this is
good
oh boy
hello ladies and gentlemen this is gnn
gregory news network a christian based
now he's a christian-based dude that's a
starbucks i'm here at starbucks coffee
a long time ago breaking news i used to
live in california yes you did i was
friends with christian many earthquakes
there earthquakes through a big
earthquake in los angeles earthquake
january 17 1994
the background you know so this song is
dedicated to people
and i've gone through big earthquakes
it's called the earthquake song and
here's a portion of it a portion you
know a teaser when
the earth starts to rumble
don't take a tumble and trust in god
when
the earth
starts to rumble don't take the tumble
in trust in god
that's in the lord jesus christ trust in
him and god the father the interlude
my savior my lord this is like in boys
girl right when
the earth starts to rumble
take a tumble and trust in
james gregory jr
when the earth starts to rumble
don't take the tumble and trust in god
burped
that's
he said that's dedicated to anyone who's
gone through a big earthquake
it was just ten days after my wife and i
got married january 7 94 in los angeles
i always like that about him he talks
about his wife all the time well i don't
think they're together anymore why
because i think she left him oh it was
the biggest natural disaster
the wedding american history no not true
kill
hurricane katrina
it did an estimated over 20 billion
dollars in damage
uh in the los angeles area that quake
okay
and the
and unfortunately
80 people died in that earthquake
freeways collapsed
buildings collapsed houses collapsed
cars were crushed and like i said
unfortunately there were 80 people who
lost their lives
in the northwoods quakes in one
apartment complex that's the biggest the
san fernando valley
it was a three-story
apartment complex yeah i guess okay
that's good for him that that's the
second biggest natural disaster in
american history 80 people died
no when the earth takes a tumble and
wait it sounds just like him
and when the earth starts to rumble
don't take a dumbbell
james gregory
such [ __ ] lyrics you know
there's some the shittiest [ __ ]
lyrics ever calvin would even be like
that's a song calvin would you make up
yeah dude kodak black would sing that
all right cool well our advice to him is
just keep on [ __ ] reporting the news
dude we're not gonna stop anyway so it
doesn't matter what we tell them i
always i always had a conversation with
that dude i hope he's doing well i hope
he's not struggling too much and um
you know we had we had good times at
that coffee shop i like yeah he was he
was actually fun to hang with for sure
yeah all right cool well let's get into
it let's do it [ __ ] man i almost started
crying laughing that was hilarious dude
the burp in the middle
[Laughter]
all right let's do it
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey boys love you both quick
question how do you write a good best
man speech
um i'd be nice to be best man at a
wedding next year it's going to be in
front of over 150 people
which isn't the problem it's the
material that i'm concerned about um how
do you write something that is funny
respectful
but you know entertaining all at the
same time
um yeah i just don't know
um
matt you give great advice and chris
you're a stand-up so i'm sure you guys
can hook me up here
love you from alex you look great chris
you look funky
um
all right so um
i don't know man you can sing the
earthquake song yeah you always could do
that especially if you're in california
i mean look dude you know well actually
at [ __ ] jordan's wedding our cousin
got married this this this uh weekend uh
and and i went you didn't because you're
about brother and yeah because
yeah my bad brother though because i
wanted to go to really just bad family
members so
um i gave [ __ ] speeches of your [ __ ]
i know i know i know i know both [ __ ]
killing killing things they're great and
you're done you're just like a dick
tracy villain too pam and pimping uh and
so
i was dressed like a dick at your
wedding yeah yeah
and so um
so uh
[Laughter]
the guy the guy who did the uh we got to
get a picture okay
the guy who did the the
best
man speech at jordan's wedding said
uh he said something really funny you
should just steal it but he was like
he was like uh there were
this room is full of great men it's full
of
uh great lawyers
great producers
you know great doctors
but today i am the best man
it was funny that's cute steal that
start with that and then um don't try to
be too funny don't try to be too funny
make it personal but not like everyone's
going to look around and be like why are
they talking about this in front of
people in the one time yeah yeah you
know people try to get too cute with it
they want to like kind of embarrass them
like they would among like a small group
of friends yeah that's not a good idea
no one's going to laugh people are going
to get upset with you but also you don't
want to [ __ ] get get like too serious
either there's like that fine line of
you want to be sweet and honest but you
want to keep it light as well so it's
like that personal thing
think of like a very like personal
story that sort of connects to the day's
events in some way or another yeah
that's a good idea and also don't uh do
inside jokes yeah i always think that
that's gonna work it's bad
and then tommy you know big big bird we
call him big bird um big bird become big
bird because uh um we would play
basketball uh in high school and anyway
but um the worst speech so
so uh so anyway they're getting married
the day i met the day i met uh the wife
the one why is the earthquake show
song by me
james gregory
[Music]
um
yeah dude i think that and and also dude
number one keep it short dude oh dude
please don't go on too long you know
you're not
make one thing silly thing in the
beginning don't do inside jokes dude
don't do inside jokes keep it short and
keep it sweet and be nice and careful
with the roasting
because i don't i think that honestly
roasting isn't the way to go that's what
i'm saying you don't want the [ __ ]
roasted up yeah in front of people
somebody's mom and [ __ ] like they don't
like that unless you're a professional
comedian like mike linocchi [ __ ]
roasted me at my wedding it was [ __ ]
hilarious but he knows how to do it yeah
he also gave the single worst speech
i've ever seen in my f
michael noche in life yeah at my wedding
yeah really yeah dude
you talking about mike linochie i know
michael anochi dragged on like a
[ __ ] it was funny oh got it okay
but like
oh i thought it wasn't the worst no yeah
it was entertaining for sure yeah it was
entertaining okay uh get your fingers
out of my face now because there's
people who are like
yeah yeah
okay okay yeah linoche was [ __ ] but
even him admittedly he was like i forgot
my no i don't know where my notes are
and he kept like going on rambling about
that thing and was like um oh yeah yeah
yeah but it was
okay i mean he was spraying the crowd
okay okay this is the earthquake song by
me
james gregory all right let's just go to
the deal with a copyright issue if you
keep singing it gonna get sued
y'all were really nice to me and you
said i was i was sweet yeah and uh you
listened to me and i just thought that
was something else i mean oh yeah it's
just pretty neat
um my son is home
i followed your advice
uh he got to meet his namesake
and my mother
and it was awesome
there was no specialty needed
but hey chris want to let you know
you're right
i do not shower very much
you were your first judgment
bazinga was so right intuitive
so i want to ask you as a man that looks
like this that is is rough looking how
do i also look clean oh and uh
thank you guys love you guys so much
you know what i mean i love that right
well dude i got to tell you man like
i
i'm with he looks clean to me
maybe he's just cleaned up for the
[ __ ] video but dude like everyone one
of the top things about me is like oh he
looks like he doesn't shower but i
shower every
single day about you you're like the
cleanest person i know i know
i'm very very clean yeah to the point
that it's like a kind of annoying yeah
um but and and people think like
because i guess i have a beard and a
that's it's just like when people have a
beard they're like don't shower but that
that's a strange thing the thing about
that is that beard looks
it's not trimmed at all it's very
unknown it's too long to be
in the world
well yeah it's too long to be looking
clean unless you trip you've got to trim
it yeah so i don't think really you can
do anything unless you trim your beard i
mean to look clean
if you were dressed in a tux to the
nines you'd still look dirty because
it's not trimmed that
is signifies not taking care of yourself
right
yes it does but it shouldn't but it
shouldn't and times may be changing but
buddy we ain't there yet yeah yeah right
yeah we're just not there yet as a
society we live in a society you know
what i mean yeah yeah we do um so he
looks like he does not but right he
actually does not he looks like he yeah
he has to work knows more animals than
humans but um
yeah man i i i don't know if there's a
way to do it unless you trim a little
bit your beard and your mustache if you
have here's the thing if you have the
mustaches that go and curl up back into
your teeth
forget it you're dirty you could wash
three times a day yeah that's
no one wants to even see that he doesn't
have that if you're tasting follicle i
mean i don't know i don't that's
disgusting even follicles
oh look a dog
lost your mind
um on acid just tripped so hard there's
a dog over there pass the camera so um
what you did is what a guy who does the
best man's speech should not do because
the audience wasn't involved it was so
much but yeah right yeah we were it was
an inside joke then i had to explain it
right okay but it wasn't an inside joke
it just appeared before an inside thing
okay okay well now you're pissing me off
though so that's fine but that's fine
right okay because you made a mistake
okay uh but he doesn't to me honestly it
doesn't look dirty it looked like his
beard was specifically shampooed oh well
to me oh do you wash your how do you
wash your thing my face no your beard
with my just wash it with my soap like
that yeah me too i never do have you
ever tried to shampoo it no tried to do
it when somebody told me how to do it
once did it broke out completely but it
was like
sucks yeah
no you shouldn't be doing that unless
you have a beard like that
right like hair right right right okay
all right cool so basically trim your
beard and that's the only way you'll
look clean you may be clean but you also
aren't clean because you don't shower
that much so there you go you admitted
it i was right i'm a detective okay
hey matt and chris my name is nick and i
live in fort wayne indiana for some
reason uh still waiting on that hbo max
set to roll up into town uh to get that
mixed race couple uh show going um
anyway
uh so this is kind of a question for
chris but matt i would love it if you
chimed in two uh chris i have a
two-year-old probably about calvin's age
a little bit younger but um
anyway where you know you hear the
age-old thing of the terrible twos you
know oh you know my kid
blah blah turns into some sort of like
demon when they're two um we have never
really believed that my wife and i have
never really believed that but we're
starting to see kind of this
terrible two streak i guess come about
in our daughter and uh you know it's
like the
the saying no all the time just being a
contrarian to be a contrarian like we
get
two-year-olds are like scientists that
are always experimenting with different
things just to see what kind of
reactions you can get so hopefully um
but it's reaching a point where like
she'll say no and it's like
no
sassy kind of like see how i did it
testing you you know what i'm saying
so chris
my question is
how do you handle this sort of stage
with calvin it sounds like on
congratulations and on this podcast that
you do have
kind of the contrarian behaviors you
have to deal with uh so how do you go
about that matt i would again i'd love
to hear your input as well sorry i went
way too long i appreciate you guys more
than i can ever express i am a true baby
for life peace nice
just real quick i think give her up for
adoption that's my no i don't know
it's kind of everything that
it's actually super weird that that's
part of the developmental process like
dude
just when they get to around two or
whatever actually my pediatrician said
it's usually
uh
it usually starts
because the first year is to one so the
second year is to two
so she's like it's the second year
usually so it starts
before two oh that's what she said with
calvin it didn't really start till a
little later but um
but um
yeah they do it like the chinese years
you know mm-hmm you know what they do i
don't know
me neither but not um so uh
yeah calvin says no like he says no like
about everything now yeah he said no the
other day i said you know what i really
like your hair today and he said no you
don't and like a like a vietnamese like
like that yeah and he and and he wasn't
even looking at me so he's just like
they just do that [ __ ] yeah because they
know oh i don't have to do
[ __ ] i have free will though
[ __ ] but what's interesting is
that they don't because everyone does it
at that phase in their life it's like
they don't have free will they need to
say no to everything the matrix you know
what i'm saying yeah it's just like it's
automatic with cow i've noticed it for
sure he's just like it's like this
beyond an impulsive yeah like he has
it's like you do it you think you know
you think you got the choice to do it
but it was your destiny yeah to say no
yeah you saying no is so [ __ ] typical
and obvious you being a real rebel you'd
say yes to everything yeah right wow i'm
going to tell him that when he
understands it when he's older yeah so
yeah really he's you're just it's part
of it's part of it
this was designed if you were a real
rebel
you would say yes to everything i want
you to do yep
that's when i start telling to people
adults and everything also you just did
it
you just are saying no
basically i have that's me that did that
because i i
i splurted you made him i made you you
half of you half of kristen yeah right
yeah so i made you so you're saying no
because i designed that wow so say that
to your daughter i think he's got a
daughter say that to your daughter worst
dad ever imagined i designed you i
designed you to say no but calvin does
this thing too or he stops because
that's what peppa pig does and he loves
and he goes like this no i don't and
it's really cute and it's hard not to
smile because when he says no it's so
cute
and then you kind of smile but you kind
of got to like turn your head that seems
like trouble yeah you don't want to let
them know it's enjoyable when they say
no right mm-hmm mm-hmm or but do you let
them know it's enjoyable no i don't call
it i don't i you try not to i go oh yeah
like that yeah so i'm like kind of
laughing but it's like oh okay here we
go do a turn of events so yeah so that's
really what you got to do also well i
actually didn't give any advice but
devices what you can do is the art of
diversion right because like kids are so
oh i'm doing one thing then i'm doing
another thing oh more colors oh a
cartoons on ooh construction paper right
mm-hmm oh a truck drove by
if they say no hey like calvin he never
wants to eat i'd be like we gotta go eat
he goes like no i don't and i say hey
look at this toy and he was like oh and
he takes a toy and then i take him and
put him in the high chair he doesn't
even notice and then he starts eating
all of a sudden
dumbass he is no it's not i would never
fall for that yeah i know because you're
[ __ ] you're 38 right yeah okay so
he's two so this is what he's talking
about he's two his daughter's two rather
my son's two so that's what they do
right you're 38 it wouldn't work on you
but i actually have a feeling it would
like the mentality kind of [ __ ] it could
yeah i could i like toys but be the
mentalist to your to your daughter or
whatever right art of diversion right
right yes dude by the way we have uh the
lifeline i don't know if you've heard
the last episode but we have the
lifeline merch oh wait [ __ ] i should
show oh [ __ ] we got the spin move
mentality [ __ ] you know what i mean
that's just the team we got the hoodie
yeah we got the hoodie which is right
here oopsy daisy we got it in here and
then we got the uh [ __ ] uh we got
other shirts and we actually got a long
crewneck yeah the crew neck is dope i
have it in my bag i have to take it off
because it's so [ __ ] hot in la right
now but it's the [ __ ] it's actually my
favorite thing yeah the neck is kind of
when you put it on it's like oopsie
daisy you know what i mean
oops i look and feel great right right
right oh [ __ ] dude you look as good as
you feel well that's amazing yup by the
way dude i'm ugly today
dude i told you that earlier yeah what
did i say what did i say i said why and
then you got because i said oh so you
don't [ __ ] right you got your
feelings sir because i didn't
immediately disagree yeah you didn't
even go like this why yeah like here's
what you should have done say you're
ugly i'm ugly today say that me yeah i
see you i'm i'm ugly today
why'd you say that yeah i didn't do that
yeah i did do
why no what i do i do no you go why oh
yeah just completely stone-faced i'll go
oh maybe he thinks i am my intention of
saying why though was actually because i
looked at you and thought i don't
see
that so why do you think that but i
could have expressed that more i didn't
and i don't have any regrets about it
but maybe i should have done well um
you know when you put on an outfit
sometimes and you're like oh [ __ ] this
outfit's banging right yeah yeah yeah
and then like a week later or two weeks
later you put on the same outfit and
you're like wow it just doesn't feel
right oh do you do that ah i don't not
really maybe last time i wear this
outfit i felt [ __ ] fly as [ __ ] now
i'm wearing this outfit i don't feel
good no i think you look good
thanks all right next one
hey chris hey matt my name is maya and
i'm from toronto canada
i'm a huge fan of both of you i could go
on and on about it but i know i don't
have that much time no go ahead so i
just wanted to ask you about a
friendship issue
a couple of months ago back in april i
guess i broke off a friendship with
somebody who i've been best friends with
for 18 years
essentially to sum it up she started
dating this guy about a year or so back
and um i got red flags pretty much from
the get-go
she before she met him was super
enthusiastic
life really passionate and it's kind of
like a social butterfly and i
you know that's what i loved about her
after she met him i think he really dug
at her confidence and she completely
lost all self-esteem
there were just so many things going
downhill for her and he was just a
really narcissistic selfish person who
was just all about himself
i we have a judge free friendship um or
so i thought so i approached her about
it
and just gave her my opinion
as it turns out it wasn't appreciated
and she basically said that i my opinion
was unwanted and uncalled for and pretty
much i should be ashamed for saying what
i said and that i'm really judgmental
damn she went on to say some really
hurtful things and ultimately i cut her
off not even two seconds later i just
have a problem i guess it's easy for me
to cut people off but what she said just
really hurt my feelings
so i guess i'm wondering two things
number one
was it none of my business and should i
have just stayed out of it because i
have a place
and number two did i jump the gun on
ending our friendship um or did i make
the right choice anyways thanks guys
dude i think okay first of all she owes
you an apology yeah i also think just
real quick i think that
it's indicative of how she feels about
it as well that she had that reaction to
to get that crazy and that defensive
about something like that that means she
probably either agrees with you or has
had feelings along those lines as well
but doesn't want to face but i also
think though dude
that's kind of
you cut it off immediately like i don't
know what she said she might have said
something terrible if you i mean who
knows i mean cutting it off immediately
is
kind of like a huh
in your
like she's asking did i jump the gun
yeah and you're saying i don't know the
whole relationship but like it sounds
like maybe you did i don't know what she
said i mean maybe she maybe like if your
dad died or of cancer and she's like i'm
glad your dad died [ __ ] me deserved
it all right that's a different story
she's saying that
the the friend
threw things back at her about her that
she had never said before and they were
really mean that's the
well that's why i say she owes you an
apology she owes her apology but here's
the [ __ ] issue dude
the main thing is dude just
i i don't think you're judgmental but
like i think that you when it comes to
like love and who people are dating you
just gotta [ __ ] stay out of it yeah
you know like we get this these kinds of
questions a lot should i tell my [ __ ]
friend who's gonna yeah it's just i
think you just kind of gotta let them do
their thing and figure it out themselves
cause they either will or they won't and
dude love is they say love is blind for
a [ __ ] reason dude yeah you're not
gonna you're not gonna change their mind
you're not gonna change your mind that
drug love is too too
too intoxicating here's the other thing
though dude
a chick i bet this i bet this is me
supposing but i bet this girl was like i
need to talk to you can we meet for
coffee and made a whole [ __ ] thing
about it which made it way worse
this kind of thing is way better to draw
just drop little [ __ ] yeah yeah side
bombs on like dudes do test it out also
test it out see how defensive she is but
what's done is done right right what son
is done but i'm just saying for the
future and if this other girl apologizes
and you decide to rekindle your
friendship which it's been 18 years of
friendship dude drop these side bombs on
[ __ ] like dudes do because
chicks are let me let's see oh hey i
made you a card and this is the thing i
want to talk to you about and over here
and they got a laser pointer and now the
other chick is like well i'm glad your
dad died of cancer right right because
it's a whole thing but if you're a dude
right and you're just dudes are like
yeah because your girl you know your
girl does that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up and
just like we talking about it's like i'm
just saying she does it but who gives a
[ __ ] and then they're at they're doing
it literally at the club and they got
bottles and then you know that the dude
disproves of the [ __ ] girl and that's
a side bomb because it seeks it seeps
inside of your your buddy and he kind of
gets the idea and that's where the idea
grows
but when you come [ __ ] blindsiding
like that
we gotta i guess you're not blindsided
you're setting it up but it sounds like
she made a whole thing about it sounds
like she made a whole thing about it but
it's a bad it's a bad move it's about i
don't know what the friend said but it
could have been
[ __ ] horrible it could have been this
woman who's calling in might have had no
[ __ ] choice of course yeah it could
have been yeah but i'm just saying a lot
of it sounds a little bit like
it could have been handled differently
by both of you and it sounds like it
sounds like uh
yeah that's that's all i gotta say yeah
i mean i i don't
based on the fact that i don't know what
she said to you maybe you jumped the gun
maybe you didn't only you can know
really uh
because you know the what she actually
said um as far as the other thing
uh it's hard to be friends with someone
to continue to be friends with someone
when you slowly see them disappear
from did their old self disappear and
then become a new self sort of shaped by
their partner who you already don't like
and think is about influence so i get
why you would
back off from that friendship uh anyway
but i don't think that uh
this is never going to work if you just
tell them that i mean i i agree with you
yeah maybe it was gone maybe it was
going away anyway maybe and this was
like the last day to get her to see the
light you know and also people always
talk about like relationships ending how
it failed like dude 18 years of
friendship that's a successful
um uh all right cool let's do the next
one
what is up lads if i made an honor show
absolutely incredible
chris has been a massive fan since the
vine days since uh wow first of all
airlines on broadway
ages ago uh
matt you're the [ __ ] man
both of you thank you for the laughs and
uh keep it going um
my question is around uh trust making
new friends uh i consider myself a
misanthropic humanist uh someone who
loves humanity but struggles with uh the
individual you know [ __ ] hate people
um because you really can't trust them
especially meeting people
in your life
and uh you could just be making up
absolute [ __ ] like that um i have
trouble trusting new people i need to
know that they're good individuals that
they're good people how do you guys go
about getting a good sense of character
finding the people that you can trust
later on in life making those new
friends um and knowing that you're
surrounding yourself with new good um
kind-hearted people
love y'all too wait why'd you look at me
like that why did his voice change so
much did it
what are you talking about i didn't
notice that at all
yes play it again
what is up lads uh if i made it on the
show absolutely incredible
british chris has been a massive fan
yeah since the vine days since uh i
first saw you on caroline's on broadway
ages ago uh
matt you're a [ __ ] man you're the
[ __ ] man both of you thank you for
the laughs and uh
thank you all right now watch our
question is around uh trust making new
friends uh
i consider myself a misanthropic
humanist
someone who loves humanity but struggles
with uh the individual you know [ __ ]
hate people um
you really can't trust them especially
meeting people later on in your life
still british and uh you could just be
making up absolute [ __ ] like that um
i have trouble trusting new people i
need to know that they're good
individuals that they're good people
yeah how do you guys go about getting a
good sense of character what finding the
people that you can trust later on in
life making those new friends um and
knowing that you're surrounding yourself
with new good um kind-hearted people
what
it did change bro dude is this a trick
this is he's talking about trust and
he's [ __ ] trying to lie to us about
where he's [ __ ] from bro this is
crazy dude it really did i know because
i'm out big fan massive fan i'll tell
you this much it's mantle
it's absolutely mental anybody that ever
says you're not funny i say bullocks i
say bollocks my butler was telling me
this the other day i got so upset i
threw down my tea and trumpets
anyway is it really hard to trust people
or
so weird one of the weirdest [ __ ]
things good catch man that's so [ __ ]
weird man what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
dude
get out of here bro [ __ ] get out of
here dude
before i realized it this is what i was
gonna say yeah go ahead is
bro it's you're living exhausting
it's exhausting to do that just [ __ ]
meet people and just see what uh yeah
it's exhausting dude yeah you you oh am
i gonna trust this person am i gonna
[ __ ] know i have no idea they don't
even know where you're from bro you
change the way you talk yeah yeah yeah
no one should trust you yeah look in the
mirror man you're like falcom or from
the saint in one video do it right yeah
exactly just changing identities but
yeah dude uh it's exhausting it's
[ __ ] exhausting to live like tupac be
like trust nobody who knows what the
[ __ ]
and he ended up dead yeah i mean dude
just so
just people are shitty people are not
shitty like the same person can be
shitty yeah uh and not shitty about just
about different things it's too
you're making it seem too black and
white yeah yeah yeah people aren't
exactly dishonest but just because
they're not forthcoming and super honest
about every single thing doesn't mean
they're like you can't trust them yeah
people are weird but the other thing is
people generally are trustworthy because
they deep down know
the world can't work if everyone's
[ __ ] lying all the time wow the world
cannot work and people know that and so
they generally
are trustworthy because they want you to
be trustworthy as well they want the
people around them they want to be able
to trust other people and i don't know
if you've noticed i mean i think you
[ __ ] notice because you're obviously
a weird person and not exactly worth
warranting trust because you don't have
the same [ __ ] accent from one word to
the next but the people that tell the
most lies are the most
[ __ ] crazy about being lied to or the
possibility about being lied to you
about trusting other people
[ __ ] that don't trust people
are liars
not obviously all of them
yeah people that are up to the worst
[ __ ] assume other people are up to the
worst [ __ ] it's just like the most
innocent people are super [ __ ]
trustworthy because that's generally how
it [ __ ] goes oh yeah because they
feel like well why wouldn't they be like
me yeah they're just like well there's
no nobody's a piece of [ __ ] so i'm just
going to that's right
that's why like i think that everybody's
got a big dick because i'm like oh
that's actually not at all what i'm
talking about but that's a version of it
you're saying people think that
people are trustworthy because you're
trustworthy or whatever yeah and i'm
saying that's why that
that is a hundred percent why i always
think everyone has a huge
monster
you know what i'm saying okay but anyway
i think my point is about you
but i do want to get back to this
[ __ ] guy
who who has done one of the weirdest
things i've ever said that is weird
anybody do he started out
massive man like [ __ ] liam gallagher
yeah and then he ended up like [ __ ]
eric irvine down the block growing up
you know wow yeah yeah yeah i know it's
crazy bro but i have a feeling he has
honestly his penis if you were to lay it
on the table it would go across the
table and then hit the floor on the
other end so uncomfortable just so not
so not good
living for sex for anything all right
cool let's do it
yo what's up
first off your singing voices are
impeccable both so sexy second off chris
i'll be seeing you in lakeland yeah
is something or the most important thing
to expect being a first-time dad i
appreciate it
hell yeah captain short and sweet
dude the guy in the florida hat dude he
had a hat with the state of florida
no words and [ __ ] dude this was so
undone i was too busy looking at his
chest yeah the guys just and the [ __ ]
mirrored glasses he was laying back so
he was ramping right
just a good old boy going to see us in
lakewood oh yeah obviously yeah yeah
yeah lakeland i'll be in lakeland
florida chrisley.com so um
what i think the first advice for the
first time dad um dude uh
everyone says this it's so corny oh but
it's so true oh
it just goes by so
quick man okay live it
up enjoy it take them shades off
look in your son or daughter's eyes put
that florida hat backwards so you don't
miss a thing dude
i don't want to close my eyes
i don't want to say goodbye cause i'm
missing you and i don't want to miss a
thing
that wasn't bad but it also was not the
lyrics dude no it wasn't but it was it
was the best you've ever sang
i don't want to close my eyes
oh my god i don't wanna miss a thing
cause i miss you baby and i don't wanna
miss
take off your mirror glasses turn around
in florida
not the college but the actual outline
in the state and unborn you should
let your chest happen out i'm on your
shirt so low that it shows your pubes i
don't wanna clone my
[Music]
gonna hurt yourself so
[ __ ] gonna be so hoarse for four
[ __ ] days
wow [ __ ] i gotta go on tour your voice
is [ __ ] shredded for the next few
days
you're right no
um
yeah dude don't miss a thing man turn on
that aerosmith song man it's beautiful
okay it's beautiful and don't be afraid
to cry men sometimes have that stigma
dude i cried all the time with my son i
love my son so much dude oh [ __ ] it's so
beautiful i am so excited for you it's
great man it's great you do cry a lot
you cry a lot i noticed
[Laughter]
an evil villain you said it first so i
thought i could agree you cry a whole
hell of a lot
i do
card yesterday
yeah
okay
jerking off two guys
[Laughter]
i don't wanna oh dude take it easy
you're gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] voice up
i don't wanna close
off
my
heart
i'll take it right to the face i won't
miss it baby
all right enough singing for you
everybody likes it gonna get demonetized
um so uh
yeah dude don't miss a thing man what if
that guy when he was doing the video had
no pants on
i mean you may have been that surprised
that guy's [ __ ] chilling living on
his terms you know you think i'm a good
singer though
no but that was that was that was kind
of okay
dick yeah all right next one
what's up guys uh i'm currently i don't
mess with cats in my office so i have a
little bit of privacy to record this
video but here's the situation
there's a girl that i find attractive uh
here at work i've never met her yes but
i would like to meet her and i would
also like to ask her out i might be
potentially interested in asking her out
because she's walking it back um
but the problem is she
oh boy he's at a desk around a ton of
other people with other desks and
there's not much of a partition between
them either oh no so it doesn't usually
feel appropriate to just go over
and strike up a conversation with
someone i'm not i'm not in her
department she's at the other end of the
building wow how would you guys approach
that
and then also like is it even
appropriate you know to to ask somebody
out at work um how do you go about that
without causing an hr issue obviously
don't be a creep right right um i don't
think i have that problem but i think
it's just like a matter of like
how do you even go about that have you
guys ever done that in the past ask
somebody out that you work with
um
and also why does chris look like this
when he's in public
that's good i do whoa anyway thanks guys
but also in private yeah he's not that's
not for show yeah i do you don't know me
in private bro when i'm in private i'm
even more like that but i'm in private
oh
that's weird
you're doing all right when you're in
private
um i think
it's not appropriate it's not
appropriate but also if you're gonna do
it don't do it at work you gotta do it
off yeah even if it's just right outside
the yeah right outside oh
yeah
you know what do you
are you in a different because i think
you're in a different department okay
but
do you fancy going to dinner sometime
well that was the other thing i was
going to say
separate the yeah i want to meet her i i
was going to go on the same date with
her like do the meeting thing first and
maybe even a couple times then when she
feels like she knows you and when you
feel like you know her
then you can ask but dude don't conflate
the two hey [ __ ]
ever or at all meet her yeah
hey guy you don't know first things
first meet her dude hey guys i'm just
calling in um so there's a girl i don't
know her yet she works in my
uh uh building
um how do i marry her
like it's [ __ ]
like like it's a [ __ ] like it's
arranged how do i approach her about
having uh our uh uh son i don't know if
she wants
but i want to carry on my lineage um
and how do i convince her to name him
gary yeah
like you know hey guys yeah getting a
little out of here hey guy
meet her meet her at work but ask her
out away from work
i don't know how that can happen i don't
know what the [ __ ] routine of the
deal is sounds like it's
impossible anyway to ask her out in her
at her work station but you don't want
to do that anyway that's not because of
the office that's because bro there's no
way to do that where you're not going to
be [ __ ] scentsy yeah and you're not
going to be [ __ ] it up and so
insecure
there's no way you're going to do it
without being a creeper
i'm just going to say that it's also
going to be creepy yeah even if you're
even if you're super not creepy you're
gonna come off creepy i mean you're
gonna be like a [ __ ] ben stiller
character yeah dude yeah for real yeah
all right yeah do it outside of work for
sure but first meet me
go outside and [ __ ] wait for her to
come out or something [ __ ] and be like
oh sh hey what's up you work at the
thing right park next to her like
work a little bit
work a little bit make it seem natural
but but have it [ __ ] get a job on
postmates and [ __ ] have her pick you
wow wow you know what i mean don't you
just come back at del taco meet her at
work just go up to her like make a
friend at her at the station next to her
and then you can be like oh
let's include her in the conversation
[ __ ] walk by be like yo you look like
i'm like you look like my cousin and
then [ __ ] keep walking or just some
[ __ ] interesting you know what i mean be
interesting walk by and be like you got
kids and keep going
you know what i mean it's not creepy you
just be weird but she's like why did
that dude do that that's a little creepy
you got kids i mean yeah maybe the kids
thing but like oh [ __ ] you look good
with a beret i gotta get out of here wow
and moonwalk away spin move oh dude if
you
and spin move out that
forget it does the spin move
make you attractive yeah oh that's one
of the things about the spin move it's
not just
own the situation and and get the [ __ ]
out of your own you're turning how
[ __ ] sexy are you you probably have
to hand her a towel on it i guess that's
true sit on this
hey hey
you look good in a hat
sit on this and then just moon walk away
wow i mean you're going to be all wet
would never get a d you're going to be
all wet due to my spin move well why is
he from [ __ ] why are you changing
accents like the guy in the previous
video we've been lied to who knows you
know all right all right next one
hi chris and matt my name is madison i'm
a huge fan of both shows i got the life
rips merch you know
you know how it is
um i need advice on what to do but my
ex-boyfriend so we dated for seven and a
half months and i broke up with him in
march this march way to go um and he
told me that in september he wants to
get a tattoo for me down the side of his
chest here that says if it's meant to be
in japanese writing
i'm not japanese he's not japanese so
i'm not sure if i want to be the girl
that boys get tattoos of so i don't know
if i should entertain this and let it
play out or just cut out the thread and
tell him no
what do you guys think i should do well
i don't know if you should do anything
besides
never associate with this guy ever
[ __ ] again ever i mean that's harsh
but also what the [ __ ] he's crazy he's
like [ __ ] some max katie [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is this what max katie why is
he [ __ ] robert de niro in cape fear
why is he getting a
[ __ ] tattoo
i've been thinking about getting a
tattoo
why is he doing like japanese you guys
broke up
if it's meant to be
in japanese also why is that for her
i'm assuming he told her i want to get
this tattoo
because it makes me think of you i want
to memorialize you on my body and then
it goes like this
the japanese [ __ ] has to go unless you
get japanese it's also not usually
japanese that people have written on
them it's like sanskrit no it's
different sometimes it's japanese yeah
sometimes yeah but a lot of the times oh
okay yeah so okay you know watch your
mouth when you say that yelling at me
okay yeah um
no but yeah i mean that's
don't do anything don't do anything
don't do anything besides stop
associating with this guy i mean you
broke up in march what is it
[ __ ] august yes
what's going on here you know what i
mean are you broken up or not why would
he get a [ __ ] tattoo for you that's
her point though her point is how weird
is this he wants to get a tattoo wants
to get it to two
audrey tattoo no he wants to get a
[ __ ] tattoo
of
not of her but to
you know to honor maybe they're friends
or something no i don't think so i think
she's just like telling you
yeah it's weird should i tell him or
what should i do nah just leave it alone
don't do anything don't do anything you
know people will do what they do
yeah maybe just drop it out just try to
try to [ __ ] make it you know people
like that time goes just okay oh that's
cool people like that do things
to get a person who's out of their life
who they want still in their life to
remain in their life and i don't mean
the image of the tattoo i mean he can
tell you about it he can talk he's got
something to talk about it not just oh
hey how's the weather exactly right
right right that is not only sad but
you're doing a [ __ ] disservice in the
long run by still talking to him stop
talking to him he's it's not going to
help him and honestly it's [ __ ] bad
for you this guy's going to he's going
to kill somebody at some point in his
life at some point in this life that
guy's going to kill him no i don't know
i'm not saying it's you but yeah
something bad's gonna happen i mean come
on bro a tattoo of basically of his
ex-girlfriend
seven months after they broke up that's
pretty weird yeah that is so [ __ ]
true
and people that weird people that like
throw you for such a loop about you yeah
maybe just be like maybe just be like yo
dude we're broken up but like why would
you do that yeah but don't do that you
know what i mean
yeah i mean yeah
kind of giving him what he wants even
then i think that just but we don't know
this is one of those things we don't
know if it's like you know maybe they're
still friends i guess yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah wow
if you're still friends and he wants to
do it just be like you're [ __ ] you
know what you do you get a tattoo that
says it's not what was
gonna say if it's meant to be
and have it in japanese
it's not yeah yeah look at mine and he
goes what does that mean and you say you
[ __ ] idiot speak japanese you don't
know and you've got japanese on your
[ __ ] rib cage wow i don't want to
close my eyes wow
i don't wanna say goodbye cause i miss
you baby and i don't wanna miss a thing
cause i have to show it i [ __ ] hate
when you do the [ __ ] vibrato thing i
so you don't like good singing
i don't want to close my eyes
that's okay
that's good that's better than the
[ __ ] yeah because it's emotional
i don't wanna
what does it say goodnight
he doesn't say say goodnight i don't
wanna
close my eyes i don't wanna miss a thing
because i still miss you babe and i
don't wanna miss a thing no no because
that's the same i don't think it's dmx i
don't wanna close the same thing with
the same thing i don't wanna fall asleep
i got with the i got my dogs and those
are my dogs and these are my dogs you
know dmx would be like
well the guy in those videos that
[ __ ] goes back in time uh i don't
wanna close my heart
what is the part i don't want to fall
asleep i don't want a clue is this good
dude for real okay i don't want to close
my eyes
that's good i don't want to what is it
that was good i don't want to fall
asleep cause i miss you baby and i don't
want to mess with that
yeah that was good
you don't like that before but that's
what makes it good i couldn't agree less
dude why i couldn't agree that's what
aerosmith does because it makes me angry
he doesn't do that he doesn't run like a
[ __ ] like he's in an italian opera in
1920
i don't want to close my eyes
[Laughter]
what's that opera singer i know oh i'm
cultured dude
all right and we also have the lifeline
merch at lifelinemerch.com if you have a
question click the link in the
description uh
watchlifeline.com uh send us your stuff
dude
i don't wanna close my highs
highs i don't wanna close my eyes
[Music]